Tristan Tate and brother Andrew Tate you
know them you love them you have them
you've seen them many times on the show
express interest in buying popular media
company BuzzFeed BuzzFeed is reportedly
facing Financial issues with uh losses
around 10 million dollars a year should
the Tate Brothers buy this media Outlet
because it's all about crafting your
narrative there's so much negative media
attention about the Tates out there
these days about any celebrity out there
that doesn't fit with mainstream
narrative would it be advantageous for
the Tates to say all right BuzzFeed
let's see if we can turn this thing
around and buy this thing and report on
ourselves